Show them what Lannisters are,...
...what we do to our enemies.
Game of Thrones fanatics will have another reason to watch...
...the Emmy Awards on September 18.
The HBO drama received 23 Emmy nominations...
...which were announced on Thursday.
That's more than any other show and just one less in the 24 nominations...
...it received at last year's award ceremony,...
...where it won its first Best Drama Emmy.
The announcement marked a big day for HBO too,...
...which received more nominations than any other network, with 94 this year.
Other programming that fared well in the nominating process...
...include FX's limited series "The People vs OJ Simpson: American Crime Story"...
...and the series "Fargo",...
...which received the 2nd and 3rd most nominations.